in the superior court of glenn county
state of georgia the state of georgia
versus travis mcmichael
case number cr00433
jury verdict form
count one malice murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
i'm gonna ask
oh my god hey man i'm not even mad at it
i'm not mad at it but it's just
i'm not even going front if you kill my
sibling i'll also be dancing in court
[ __ ] peanut butter jelly times
everything well you could remove me yeah
yeah contempt of court fine i would say
this what the first the first fool is
unintentional
yes the rules after that
pettiness yes i'm gonna ask that whoever
just made it out first be removed from
the court place
what do you think is running through his
minds as you realize like his life is
over
he's going to jail for life exactly that
[ __ ] yeah that's why i'm not surprised
when defendants collapse or whatever
it's like man your life is over he's not
old i don't feel bad neither do i i'm
just wondering what they think you're
the words guilty and you got to sit here
and listen to it because cause they find
you guilty on the first one they're
pretty much going to find you generally
guilty on the side yeah yeah if if if
it's the first it's a wrap yeah we the
jury find the defendant travis mcmichael
guilty
count three
felony murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
count four
felony murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
count five felony murder we the jury
find the defendant travis mcmichael
guilty
mayor if you guys looked at the evidence
if you watched the video you would know
that this was the most likely verdict
okay
some people are drawing parallels
between this and the kyle rindhouse case
and i'm like they are nothing unlike
there is
what
well
kyle didn't do anything
illegal
armory didn't do anything illegal it's
just that the position where they're at
is just different so just so you guys
have the particulars tomorrow was out
for a job apparently there have been
some burglaries in the areas and so ah
at one point he stopped in front of an
unfinished house someone came outside
saw him and thought he committed a theft
there so he the father of the man you
just saw who said be guilty went inside
got his son said grab your stuff i just
saw someone i think they did a break-in
so ahmad keeps running on his job and
they start chasing him there's three of
them who's chasing him in their cars
they try to pin him in to perform what
they call a citizen's arrest okay and
then
one of them is filming from behind
that's how you have the video that came
out and then two of them uh the other
two the father and the son they get in
front with their weapons and then they
try to cut him off afterwards ahmad runs
and he's running away from them they get
in front of him he runs towards the car
they claim self-defense after they shoot
him there and they kill him
problem is you can't do a citizen's
arrest unless you saw a crime actually
happen okay that's like you go to a
store and someone starts following you
around the store because [ __ ] know
what exactly what that's like because
they think you're stealing you haven't
done anything then they try to arrest
you it's like you can't arrest somebody
for a crime that they haven't committed
okay that's not how it works and this is
what you call vigilantism they threw the
book at these people and i'm
glad i hope they go to jail and they
stay there for the rest of their lives
okay they killed someone for a crime
that they didn't see was committed
basically that's what happened well no
it's not just they didn't say that was
committed the crime would never happen
there was no burglary he did not do and
you can't claim self-defense after you
corner somebody and then they lunge at
you it's like bruv he tried to run away
numerous times you kept going after him
then you want to say self-defense
go to jail and anybody who tries to tell
me otherwise you can miss me as well
okay i'm all for self-defense
i really believe that people should have
the right to that this is nothing like
the kyle rittenhouse case okay
kylo ren has got away
all right with killing three white
people shooting with three white people
killing two these white folks didn't get
away with killing a black man this is
extreme evidence of black supremacy
clearly
[ __ ] is just winning what the [ __ ]
we can kill white people
indiscriminately no we can't and just do
it that's not what this means
but that's what they were trying to say
they were trying to say
yeah kylo ren house getting away with
killing two white white folks in
self-defense which was clear was
evidence of white supremacy yeah they
better say this it is evidence of black
supremacy absolutely but enough trolling
aside that's true please troll in the
side please trolling inside black power
good day [ __ ] [ __ ] says
what's good my people as you know
thanksgiving is right around the corner
and i understand that this can be very
stressful for some of y'all a lot of
y'all you know there's family that's
coming over you have the whole place to
clean up they have a lot of food to prep
it's hard to stay focused and for that
uh the sponsors for this video is a
company that is called radix you can use
the products such as neural roots you
can't focus because you're home you need
to get stuff done you can't boom neural
root
all plant-based cannabis babies it's
wonderful you're too anxious you can't
go to sleep insomnia is a mother they
got your back too they have the sleepy
bears part cbd part melatonin and then
the perfect match you take that and you
take that nap and for black friday you
go on radix remedies dot com slash abba
and preach that's a b a and preach enter
promo code preach on radix remedies dot
com slash abba and preach and get 35 off
oh and with every purchase you got to
manage you to get free cbd for a year
for you know listen it's a tragic thing
to happen these [ __ ] chased
them down and gunned them down yup you
know like imagine how scared you have to
be to have like random white folks in
cars and guns chasing you down telling
you to stop they want like who are you
you know what it made me think of a time
to kill
what do you mean the girl was walking
home and they passed yeah i didn't chase
him with him they stalked her but i
guess you know what i'm saying
[Music]
great movie this is the right verdict
and you know i think self-defense is
extremely important
um i happen to live in a place right now
where you don't have those same rights
no you don't have the same ability to
defend yourself from people who are
trying to attack you and it's something
that you should want you know remember
that case with with the nurse who was um
apparently sleeping in bed and the cops
did a no knock warrant and they shot up
this place and the boyfriend was
shooting back brianna taylor right they
dropped the charges against the man who
was shooting in and ended up striking
striking one of the cops why because
they said there was self-defense right
they performed a no-knock warrant all
right i might have the details not
perfectly well but anyways he shot in
self-defense because he didn't know who
it was no it's just some people shooting
at him right and because the
self-defense laws are in place it is
legal for him to shoot at somebody who's
going after him okay that's important we
need that yeah you need to have that
right maybe it's just me i don't know
how you guys want to live your life i
think that if you are in your place of
residence and someone's barging in or
something's happening or someone's
trying to come up on you when you're
trying to keep your distance you have
the right to self-defense if someone's
attacking you i don't care what they're
doing with a pencil with a knife with
whatever shoot the [ __ ] i don't
care if there's ten of them chasing you
shoot them all what right do you have to
ask for equal retaliation when you are
the one who's initiating aggression wipe
them off the map you're gonna get zero
sympathy for me
between this case and um you know and
the kyle ring house i was hearing some
of the dumbest things
from lefties on this topic it blew my
people that didn't have all the
information lies you believe in it with
everything that was in the media but
when it was time to have due process and
facts you didn't believe it ruff ruff
they've been saying all kinds of crazy
stuff they'd be saying oh he crossed
state lines with a gun he's never been
in that neighborhood was already in the
state and so therefore it's legal for
him to have it there like the amount of
like misinformation that's been out
there yes people calling him a white
supremacist you know what's funny about
kyle redhouse he's a he's a blm
supporter he's been his whole life i'm
not a racist person i support the blm
movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
some people still think that he shot
black people
that's what i'm trying to say like what
it's cause what was written in the news
was written in the way it was written in
the news it was written
kyle rittenhouse
shot
anti-racist
some of them actually said no some of
them actually said he shot black people
yeah
so he got away with killing i'm like bro
this has happened like months ago you
could have at least googled the [ __ ]
the white [ __ ] i died up in heaven
like hey man i'm cool but i'm not that
cool
do i get an n pass in heaven now like
there's been a lot of ridiculous
surrounding these trials and i think you
know one thing that fascinates me with
people it's like
oh if he gets off then it's white
supremacy if they're found guilty then
it's just a system doing what it was
supposed to do originally it's like
breath you guys can't have it both ways
maybe we need to acknowledge one there's
some deficiencies in the system yes that
there's some racial bias in the system
and that sometimes the system does its
job
okay but people whining about
self-defense loss someone said to me
this okay this was crazy i don't want to
do that this is crazy
she said
oh she said yeah yeah you know white
women she said to me
yeah well they were running at kyle but
they didn't have a gun it's like this
this is not equal retaliation you take
if you try to take my gun away from me
and you're saying if you try to take my
gun away from me the first person i was
shot try to take his gun away
and you can't and i run i leave the
person with the gun
is not the person
getting out he's being chased let me
simplify it if i try to punch you you're
allowed to shoot me right if i if i'm
back in a way you try to swing at me i
don't have to respond with a punch this
is not mma there's not mixed martial
arts this is in the streets okay i don't
know what you have in your pockets i
don't know what you might swing with
next well he just swung a skateboard so
if it knocks him unconscious and they
take his gun and just kill him it's over
okay and you have to go
with the last law says if he feels like
he was in danger yup self-defense and
that's what happened that's it guys the
worst thing is that kyle stayed there
when he shot the person called the
paramedic and left when he was chased
again by other people yo get this guy
get this guy self-defense again yeah i
really wanted to put him in jail
for the right reason
but did i look at everything like i was
like it would serve the per yeah you
shot people you go but that's not what
happened that's these are not the facts
if you look at the facts
it's not what happened no this stance
this this verdict is the correct one i'm
glad they came to this verdict and the
media who's complicit and [ __ ] making
this whole hub bub much worse than it
actually is or making it like a much
more racially charged than it needs to
be you should be sued yes you should be
dead if you're spreading misinformation
you should be through it's not just
trump all right you guys do it too okay
so that's something that needs to also
be addressed because why it's it's
fermenting
hatred it's fermenting um a lot of the
resentment that people are creating for
for these rides and these things like
that so let us know what you guys think
in the comments below in regards to the
case in the verdict we want to hear from
you guys